26,3 pour cent des électeurs se sont
abstenus au premier tour de cette
élection présidentielle qu'en sera-t-il
au second tour si on remonte le temps en
1965 l'abstention aux deux tours et à
environ 15% en 1969 c'est une autre
histoire au second tour georges pompidou
et face à alain poher et le troisième
homme de cette élection le communiste
jacques duclos appel à l'abstention
la bourgeoisie de notre pays présente en
somme deux candidats qui sont des
cousins germains
si ce n'est des frais de 6 à voir si
vous voulez suivre mes conseils ou de
retrait ni pour pompidou ni pour plaire
résultat l'abstention explose au second
tour +2 31% alors pour l'élection
suivante en 1974 il faut convaincre les
français de se rendre aux urnes votez
votez oui vingtaine ont voté x ou y mais
votez pour une raison simple dans un
pays comme la france ou la droite et la
gauche s'équilibrent à peu près quelques
milliers de voix peuvent faire basculer
une majorité
ils iront voter au second tour c'est
valéry giscard d'estaing contre françois
mitterrand un combat droite gauche et
une abstention au plus bas un peu plus
de 12% la vraie différence c'est la
présidentielle de 2002 au premier tour
+2 28% des français ne se déplace pas un
record et le résultat c'est jacques
chirac contre jean-marie le pen une
claque pour les abstentionnistes
certains abstentionnistes hante
semble-t-il de se rattraper entre
guillemets au lendemain du premier tour
on s'empresse en effet de remplir les
formulaires de procuration
c'est important après ce qui s'est passé
au premier tour que les français rage et
ça en glace et fasse barrage au front
national
la honte ramène certains français aux
urnes au second tour
mais la fonction repent suit sa
progression au fil des présidentielles
2007 2012 2017 cette fois 22 % des
électeurs s'abstiennent au premier tour
mais à la différence de 2002 la présence
de l'extrême droite ne fera pas revenir
les abstentionnistes ils seront même
plus nombreux au second tour en france
plus de 25 % des électeurs ont choisi
l'abstention un record depuis 1969 voter
pour l'un pour l'autre c'était nourrir
l'un ou l'autre quoi qu'il arrive et et
comme je fréquente ce n'est ni le
libéralisme
taffin choisir entre la peste et le
choléra je veux pas pour m'aider next
rating reprise et de choisir au second
tour d'une élection présidentielle
c'est peut-être ce que certains citoyens
décideront de faire le dimanche 24 avril
[Musique]